[Music]
Tim you recently had your honeymoon I
did I did yeah like a weeks ago huh
doesn't want to talk about it dude
[Applause]
tell me again my baby how would you feel
[Laughter]
so in your parents would have surprised
you and been in the exact same resort
you were at with gia how would you react
I would have laughed first then probably
would have been like what the [ __ ] guys
my honeymoon you know I'm trying to
enjoy this time with my wife and then we
all would have snuggled if I saw my
parents at the same divorce and divorce
if I saw my parents at the same resort I
would have been like guys been divorced
for 20 years well you saw your parents
at the same divorce you did what I have
in front of me is a would I be the
[ __ ]
so hey oh yeah I love these would I be
the [ __ ] for running away on our
honeymoon so here's what they wrote my
husband and I on our on our honeymoon
his parents gifted us a week in an
all-inclusive hotel at no cost to us as
a wedding gift and we were really
grateful on arriving we found out that
they'd also booked a room at this whole
selves for the whole week and wanted to
do group things honeymoon don't you know
that [ __ ] that Nick's gonna be all up
in that throw I'm concerned because that
dicks about to be in my throne don't you
know what a honeymoon is for okay okay
so then no so throat focus though
we're trying to prepare and throw how
was your honeymoon oh I thought you're
trying to make a baby sometimes and you
usually doesn't happen like you know it
doesn't happen immediately they're doing
the throat [ __ ] the booty [ __ ] all kinds
of other [ __ ] that's constant but
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] dick crossed my
mind I'm concerned for your white
sweater but you know what [ __ ] here
no quarter if you put a little say on
past children right you're right Calvin
isn't that why bachelorette parties
girls do a deep throat contest with the
beer bottles you know what's up so they
practice right they actually do that yep
that's not just tradition I thought they
did Madonna documentaries oh yeah it's
an American tradition that's the only
scene I remember yeah yeah so she
continues outside of this we see then
maybe two or three times a year for a
couple of days at a time as he finds
them a bit overbearing at times
oh my smoker they don't really like me
it's not it's not like they're in our
room next door or anything and we can
still do stuff in our room alone but
they knock on our door regularly waking
us up at 6:00 a.m. making us get all
three meals a day with this oh oh my we
have tried telling them we wanted alone
time for our honeymoon
like we could hold an hour hello they
drugged us off saying that's what our
room is for we also tried faking illness
to get out of eating with them and they
just got room service to our room and
sat with us while we fix looming man
they don't like hurt me so what they'll
just say wow I think that's why they're
doing it because they don't like real
trust they're not gonna have let you
have a new date honey when you should
have so anyway so then she continues my
husband snapped earlier and said this
whole thing was way over the line and
they had no right intruding on our
honeymoon
of all things and they told us that they
paid for this whole thing and that as
adults were allowed to take holidays at
the same time at this to the same place
I'd like get your money back I'm getting
out here okay they also said is a free
country
it's a free country I could book
whatever hotel I was like okay okay Wow
okay continue we've been talking and we
saved up to pay for our own honeymoon
before they surprised us we still have
the money we would have spent in our
joint wedding slash honeymoon account
there's another town we wanted to go to
on our honeymoon and we looked it up and
we could get tickets from here to there
and then back home for less than 60
pounds total we do it we could also book
a few days in a nice hotel for about
half of what's left in our honeymoon
fund and use the remainder of the week
we booked off in another town without
his parents knowing we left until we had
it's 9:00 p.m. now their streets from
here to the other oh my god they're
escaping plus half hourly trains
tomorrow would it be would we be the
[ __ ] if we ran away from his parents
without telling him updates our train
should be arriving in our final station
in 30 minutes we found a hotel it's able
to take us tonight we're very excited
about the next four days they decided to
post this to get the Internet's like
approval approval pretty much because
they're like are we the parents are
super-nice for paying for it yeah but
then there I would write a letter like a
mom and dad thank you guys so much for
paying where this should I know it means
a lot and you guys took it out of
retirement but [ __ ] you we're getting
the [ __ ] out of here and see you guys
later but also their parents are like
next level because you know even if my
parents were silly enough to be like
let's book a trip with you at the same
time as your honeymoon if I told them
all right cool we'll see you guys at
dinner or something just give us our
time to do our thing they'd be like yeah
cool they get it but these people are
overbearing they don't like her so I
really think they're doing this [ __ ] on
purpose right like well don't attack any
people first of all don't attack many
people but no but okay so so my family
when you hang out with my family it's
the most boring thing your and your
whole life right they'd sit thought my
dad sits there like this they all have
like some [ __ ] TV show or movie on
and everyone's just sitting in a circle
people barely talk okay that sounds
peaceful fast-forward to it's my bath
relax it's my bachelor party okay we go
to Las Vegas Nevada the [ __ ]
sensitive yes where anything goes
my brothers are also in my groom party
because you know I'm getting married
yeah one of my brother-in-law has a kid
at this point and my sister is also in
the right party so everyone goes to to
Vegas for our bachelor and bachelorette
party because we did it all in Vegas so
my parents my parents showed up because
they were gonna take the kids so that we
could all just [ __ ] around nobody has to
worry about my brother-in-law doesn't
work with kid and all this [ __ ] well
unfortunately my parents decided to hang
out a bunch of kids we're at the [ __ ]
kids that's the problem we got this sick
ass suite in the cosmopolitan like it's
like the wraparound seat wraparound
sleep so nice and my parents like follow
us upstairs and we're like oh whoa yeah
we're all gonna go hang out upstairs
like oh it's viable gum and then there
they go up there and they got the
[ __ ] baby and we're like wait I might
put nice and cups like it's the stranger
the lines off the desk and [ __ ] right
your wife only I'm not that cool
why do you think I'm that cool but it's
so frustrating cuz then my dad's like
yeah and then my death taking their
amount and he's like oh and they put
[ __ ] kids shows on while we got the
password and oh my god was that just one
night how long this was a night this was
one night
meanwhile the strippers are like alright
so mr. green nice to know the strippers
sitting the strippers didn't arena story
to a kid yeah man this is like this is
the best job yeah but you laugh a little
confused baby China breast pasties on
and [ __ ] the baby's trying to [ __ ]
drink some milk so I'm in Vegas in this
wraparound suite with something on the
TV that's for kids while my dad's
sitting there like this yeah yeah so he
must have had the time of his life
though like he haven't had that much
excitement and angels like I get to
watch TV but now in the Vegas sweet damn
and what did Nicky do they were they
were doing their well at that point
Nicky was with me because that was when
everyone had kind of party like my buddy
left cuz he had to go early so we're all
just hanging out but we thought we'd go
back in the room
[ __ ] stuff rhyme damn so they stayed
in there until I long until we think
that Nicky was sick and gotten the [ __ ]
out of the room
oh man cuz I got drank too much I don't
feel good yeah I think he's my god I
think I need some dick to feel better
yeah your throat yeah that's the honey
yeah [ __ ] bust out the big surprise
until afterwards surprise don't surprise
do when you get married I can't wait
till we hear about where you're going
for your honeymoon you're not gonna be
I'm gonna go to your chick and be like
I'm gonna backpack lozenges yo mmm I was
gonna say where do you want it what
would you do for your bachelor party
dude oh that sounds fun
I don't know okay cuz bachelor parties
are supposed to be like your last day
single right I've done so much crazy
[ __ ] I don't know how I'm gonna top it I
think you gotta do it all together at
the same time I don't know it just
depends
let's go mini-golfing in and we'll do
Molly or something so fine can we do
that now yeah we ran out the whole park
well I think we're jogging mini golfing
with Molly's and also find people the
chicks with dicks to come play with us
[Laughter]
crazy [ __ ] that's got to be crazy and
some of them have more dicks than chicks
and some of them have more debt more
legit like how you plan dude you're
gonna plan it I'll plan it you've got
some creative ideas like knocked him off
his chair did you see that I didn't even
realize I know what he's been doing so
we gotta make it like for the record
people are gonna think that I've been
doing
wannabes of each other friends a long
time
we know buddies we know he's about to
there's already a conspiracy that I'm
having gay sex
[Laughter]
conspiring conspiring this people are
conspiring they're saying Joe is
actually it didn't work out because he's
actually gay because I was talking about
the Saudi Arabian men in my DMS that
want to just cook for me naked in the
apron we're guys though and when it's on
the Internet and so therefore we are gay
you see I'm saying because they have to
solve us yeah oh what people assume you
just they just assume you're gay they
assume we're all gay because never
happened to him of course it's not
people have people I get comments to
this day on my videos like what I'm with
cheer they're like oh I use gay this
whole time exactly yes they just found
out I'm straight at the wedding because
all your videos are so [ __ ] sexual oh
I mean I guess people don't have so much
content out so I guess um if you spend a
lot of time with David what would David
or like you know write my well yeah and
just my crew of homies were very low
just like affectionate like buddies you
know I'm saying and um and some people
think like the way I speak can be kind
of a finished there's a conspiracy about
Tim that he's compensating yeah yeah
choose a beard and I'm over oh I'm just
playing into the his [ __ ] now but like
maybe maybe I'm super over sexual in my
videos to make up for the fact that I'm
seeing if I have time people have a lot
of time speculating I'm gay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]